o un grupo de amigos se pregunta por
cuánto supera la rapidez con la que
pueden chasquear los dedos de una mano
en comparación con la otra una pregunta
muy importante en la vida cada uno de
ellos
chasquear los dedos de su mano dominante
por 10 segundos y los dedos de su mano
no dominante también por 10 segundos
si eres diestro tu mano derecha es la
dominante
si eres zurdo tu mano izquierda es la
cada participante lanzó una moneda para
determinar cuál era la mano que usaría
primero pudiera ser que si usas tu mano
dominante primero quizá ya estés cansado
al hacerlo con tu mano no dominante o
viceversa se define entonces de manera
aleatoria cuál mano van a usar primero
el siguiente cuadro muestra los
resultados de cuántos chasquidos
realizaron con cada mano la diferencia
para cada participante y un resumen de
los estadísticos
de hecho estos datos son reales son del
personal de carnac admin así que por
ejemplo tenemos aquí que jeff hizo 44
chasquidos en 10 segundos con su mano
dominante impresionante más de los que
yo creo que puedo hacer inclusive hizo
35 con su mano no dominante y bueno
podemos ver que la diferencia está
anotada aquí la diferencia de lo que
hizo con la mano dominante - lo que hizo
con la mano no dominante es igual a 9 y
se te hablaron los datos para cinco
personas también se incluye un resumen
de los estadísticos pero estos son los
realmente interesantes ya que
corresponden a la diferencia entre la
mano dominante y la mano no dominante y
lo que hicieron aquí para calcular la
media de las diferencias fue calcular la
media de estos datos que tenemos aquí
todos estos la cual es igual a 6.8
también se calculó la desviación
estándar de las diferencias que tenemos
aquí la cual resultó aproximadamente
1.60 y 4 entonces nos dicen construyen e
interpretan un intervalo de confianza
del 95% para la media de las diferencias
del número de chasquidos de los
participantes bien pausa el vídeo y ver
si puedes avanzar algo ver si tienes
idea de cómo abordar el problema lo que
es interesante aquí es que no estás
tratando de construir el intervalo de
confianza para la media del número de
chasquidos de la mano dominante o para
la media del número de chasquidos de la
mano no dominante estamos construyendo
un intervalo de confianza del 95% para
la media de las diferencias
podrías entonces decir a ver espero el
momento tenemos dos muestras aquí y la
tercera muestran que de alguna manera la
hemos construido a partir de las dos
primeras
tenemos que considerar es que tenemos un
diseño de datos apareados en un diseño
de datos apareados lo que se hace es
para cada participante para cada miembro
de la muestra se tiene un resultado de
control y uno de tratamiento en este
caso el control sería cuánto chasquidos
se pueden hacer con la mano dominante en
10 segundos y el tratamiento cuantos con
la mano no dominante en un diseño de
datos apareados lo que nos interesa son
las diferencias por lo que podemos ver
esto como una muestra de tamaño 5 para
la cual estás calculando la media de las
diferencias y la desviación estándar
para la muestra así que antes de que
calculemos el intervalo de confianza que
nos piden
recordemos cuáles son las condiciones
que debemos considerar al construir un
intervalo de confianza la primera
condición es la condición de
aleatoriedad si estuviéramos tratando de
hacer las inferencias en relación a
todos los seres humanos y su habilidad
de chasquear los dedos
esta no sería una muestra aleatoria
porque todos son participantes que
trabajan en can academy y quizás en
nuestro proceso de selección escogemos a
personas que chasquear los dedos muy
rápido sin embargo podríamos considerar
que cualquier inferencia que hagamos es
válida para este grupo de personas la
siguiente condición es la condición de
normalidad y hay dos posibilidades para
esta condición si tuviéramos una muestra
cuyo tamaño fuera mayor o igual que 30
el teorema del límite central estipula
que la distribución muestral de las
medias serán aproximadamente normal sin
embargo es obvio que nuestro tamaño de
la muestra es mucho menor que 30
podríamos entonces graficar los valores
y ver si hay algún sesgo hagamos una
pequeña gráfica por aquí si por aquí
toma el 0 al 1 al 2 al 3 al 4 al 5 al 6
al 7
al 8 al 9 y el 10 tenemos entonces un
punto para la diferencia de 9 por aquí
está otro punto para la diferencia de 5
por aquí en otro punto para 8 por acá y
tenemos otros 2 para 6 1 y 2 y bueno
esto en definitiva no parece sesgado si
contamos que la media es 6.8 está por
aquí podemos decir que la distribución
es aproximadamente simétrica por lo
tanto podemos considerar que si cumplen
la condición de normalidad este no es un
estudio ideal
tenemos un tamaño de muestra muy pequeño
y esto tal vez no sea completamente
aleatoria con respecto a toda la
población pero aún así podemos continuar
con el proceso también cuando consideras
procesos biológicos como este en el cual
nos interesa que también a una persona
chasquear los dedos lo cual parece ser
que está determinado por muchos factores
anatómicos y otras variables del cuerpo
esos procesos tienen una distribución
aprox
la mente normal no voy a profundizar en
esto pero me permite afirmar que aunque
el diseño del estudio no es robusto es
algo que puede ser divertido para hacer
entre amigos que no tengan otra cosa que
hacer muy bien la tercera condición es
la condición de independencia y con ésta
podemos estar tranquilos pues la
diferencia que obtuvo ayer no debe de
afectar la diferencia detectada por
david como tampoco la de david va a
afectar a la de kim etcétera sobre todo
si no lo hacen juntos por lo que podemos
suponer para este ejemplo que todos los
participantes lo hicieron de manera
independiente en un cuarto cerrado
cuando un observador independiente para
que no hubiera competencia entre ellos o
algo así insistimos que aunque el diseño
no es robusto aún así podemos construir
el intervalo de confianza del 95% ahora
como lo hacemos ya lo hemos hecho varias
veces nuestro intervalo de confianza
está dado por la media de la muestra en
este caso es la media de las diferencias
media de las diferencias más menos ahora
no conocemos la desviación estándar
poblacional por lo que vamos a usar la
desviación estándar de la muestra para
un intervalo de confianza de la media
usando la desviación estándar muestral
el valor crítico es el estadístico t
entonces va a ser tema estrella que va a
multiplicar a la desviación estándar las
diferencias que es justo esta la
desviación estándar de las diferencias y
esto dividido entre la raíz cuadrada de
n en este caso tenemos un tamaño de la
muestra de 5 entonces me va a quedar
entre la raíz cuadrada de 5 y ya tenemos
la mayoría de estos datos déjame
escribirlos por aquí conocemos la media
de nuestras diferencias es esto que está
aquí y si observas esas 6.8 entonces me
quedé
a 6.8 ya esto le vamos a sumar y a su
vez le vamos a restar y ahora cuál es
nuestro valor crítico de aquí bien
queremos un intervalo de confianza del
95% y cuántos grados de libertad tenemos
son uno menos que el tamaño de la
muestra así que en este caso nuestros
grados de libertad son igual a 4 ya
podemos revisar la tabla t esta es una
tabla t truncada para que quepa en la
pantalla ahora hay un par de maneras de
usarla aquí nos dan de hecho el nivel de
confianza y el hecho de que esto
correspondan a una probabilidad de la
cola de 0.25 es si deseas el 95% central
en una distribución normal porque
recuerda vas a tener 2.5 por ciento en
cada extremo lo cual corresponde a la
probabilidad de la cola eso es lo que
sucede el valor que queremos se
encuentran en esta columna cuántos
grados de libertad tenemos
van a ser cuatro grados de libertad el
tamaño de la muestra es 55 menos 14 y
entonces este es nuestro valor crítico
2.776 déjame apuntarlo 2.776 este es mi
valor crítico ok ya esto hay que
multiplicarlo por la desviación estándar
de las diferencias que es un dato que
tenemos por aquí es aproximadamente 1.60
y 4 entonces lo voy a poner aquí voy a
multiplicar a esto
1.64 y voy a dividir esto entre la raíz
cuadrada de 5 y bueno todo esto a cuánto
es igual
primero calculemos el margen de error el
cual es si sacamos por aquí nuestra
calculadora me va a quedar 2.776 2.776
que va a multiplicar a 1.64 ok y esto
dividido entre la raíz cuadrada de 5 ok
esto va a ser igual a bueno es
aproximadamente igual a 2 puntos 0 36
entonces déjame ponerlo esto va a ser
aproximadamente igual a 6.8 más menos
2.0
de lujo y si de hecho que seamos
escribir el intervalo
necesitamos calcular cuánto es 6.8 más
2.0 36 y 6.8 menos 2.0 36 es más vamos a
hacerlo me quedaría 6.8 menos 2.0 36
déjame sacar de nuevo la calculadora y
tengo 6.8
- 2.0 36 ok esto va a ser igual a 4.764
de reponerlo 4.764 command y después
tengo 6.8 + 2.0 36 lo cual lo puedo
hacer en la mente eso me quedaría 8.8 36
de lujo ahora como interpretamos este
intervalo de confianza que acabamos de
obtener una manera de interpretarlo es
afirmando que tenemos una confianza del
95% de que este intervalo contiene el
valor real de la media de las
diferencias en chasquidos para estos
amigos también podremos decir que
aparentemente hay una diferencia al
comparar el número de chasquidos dado
que el 0 no está incluido en el
intervalo y como todo el intervalo es
mayor que 0 parece que este grupo de
personas este grupo de amigos de khan
academy
más rápido los dedos de la mano
dominante por ahora es todo así que nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo